you tried stand up right I did stand up
and you I think say you were not a good
stand up I was not you did the same five
minutes over and over again well it was
on the one hand I was terrible at it on
the other hand I was sort of a savant I
I was doing like improv comedy and we
had like five minutes of sketch stuff
left over yeah I just strolled into the
comedy store and on open mic night and
did those five minutes but I would think
even if you just did Woody Allen for 5
minutes it would be a scream Howard
amazingly enough I did no Impressions I
just was all observation which probably
why it wasn't so good that wasn't your
strong suit no not at all well for some
reason Comics think guys who do
impressions are hacky they don't treat
them well I never understood that yeah
and I love guys who do Impressions Jim
Carrey did Impressions and then he goes
on to say I had to stop doing
impressions if I wanted to be taken
seriously as a standup I mean I did do
William Shatner that was part of my ACT
I would do Captain Kirk Impressions you
did that didn't kill they was okay you
know at the comedy store back then this
is in the 80s you never got through your
act you were just literally heckled like
the rabble from Shakespearean time which
Shatner did you do did you do the I
would do an impression of uh a William
Shatner taking a that sounds good
how'd that go well here it is Willam
Shatner taking a
ready I called that the Kirk two move
pain reaction like wherever Captain Kirk
got hit it there was that head or the
foot or the knee it was
always um I'm laughing well I'm glad you
liked it I like it have a predilection
for pooper humor audiences didn't
respond to that some did some didn't I
rarely got to it in the act it was
mostly about fending off uh
heckers